das auto highlight des jahres der neue
bugatti mistral für knapp sechs
millionen euro wir sind bei der welt
premiere das besondere ist dass das eben
ein cabrio ist und eines der schnellsten
elektroautos der welt was ist das bitte
für eine höllenmaschine wie unser
redakteur moritz doka so komplett zum
ausrasten bringen
[Musik]
und der neue mercedes amg c 43 mit über
400 ps das ist ordentlich bums aber er
hat noch vier zylinder kann das gut
gehen vier zylinder statt sechs das ist
natürlich wenn eingefleischte motor fans
eine mittlere katastrophe und so viele
andere leute gehen bei amg ja eigentlich
auch nicht einkaufen oder
und die autofahrer in thailand für
24.000 euro ein fake aston martin baut
wir waren vor ort und haben es
herausgefunden
auto bild das magazin mein name ist
hinter hoffmann bin tuner und ich liebe
autos ab sofort werden wir für euch
testen supersportler elektroautos
günstige autos und und und da ist
garantiert für jeden von euch was dabei
[Musik]